guys greg outta here guys it's John and
listen I gotta tell you something what
is this something Michael Bay says this
is gonna be the last Transformers movie
and guess what else man that he's
directing the he's direct guess what
else though what Daniel day-lewis just
said he's gonna retire from acting or
his rhythmic so the title might've made
you think that we thought Michael Bay
was also retiring I just wanted to see
who stood around for 15 more seconds to
realize that we meant retiring from
directing the Transformers movie off so
I'm gonna ruin your operation no John
you didn't you didn't my friend I'm not
he helped make it all clear for everyone
okay so yeah Michael Bay retiring
directing Transformers movies let's
let's talk about that person let's
address this [ __ ] horrible
[Music]
getting--getting kids can you smell
Michael Bay you smells like [ __ ]
good spirits high refrain stopping
directing these transformers movies how
many freaking times of this guy said
that he'll know I feel like I'm Michael
Jordan of frickin directing transformers
I feel like now he just does it just to
see like if they'll offer him a bit more
money that's the only reason he said
that he's smart this guy's smart he
makes movies that will produce a cool
ass trailer so we all go maybe this time
Michael Bay put his [ __ ] ego down and
was like you know what I'm gonna listen
to some constructive criticism about my
film huh and I'm going to make a good
movie at this time and they give you
that make movie trailer that doesn't
reveal how awful a sense of humor is
yeah I think it's about going to have
those good like Mark Wahlberg's on there
he's a he's a respected actor trailers
are always great always great and then
he makes dumb big movies and make over a
billion dollars somehow with
our fault Michael bass still around and
doesn't ever quit you will quit when we
stop watching his damn Transformers
really when the world stops new movies
will get better when they bring in
another director who can actually make
something worth watching out of one of
these films but there's the thing is
maybe he doesn't have to quit because
like it is a weird franchise because
every time it just gets bigger him and
despite the fact that the response just
gets worse yeah I think he just says it
for marketing reasons I think he gets
people to like want to see the movie
think about it use your living I wanna
see it who provides him it's just glass
yeah yeah yeah Michael Bay's what he's
gonna bring a dangerous yeah he's gonna
make he's gonna go with a very nothing
was like a great no I think that's why
he said that every time you throw enough
money in front of the guy guys our
producer to I mean he couldn't like
shoot stuff for sure you know he can
shoot stuff he's a good technically
technically is a good drug yeah like he
makes stuff look awesome he does and he
makes the Transformers [ __ ] look pretty
cool for the most part I'd say like the
you can't deny that's why they make
great trailers but it's like it loses
his excitement you watch eyes right here
we review the Transformers movies what
we're here to say that my couvade is
[ __ ] this is not time he's gonna
retire here what do be done well they're
gonna wave more money in front of you
know and really annoy me when he like
picked up age of extinction or that the
one the fourth one when he picked that
one back up he's like he said something
along the lines of I didn't want anyone
else to mess this up or something as if
he made like great films to be kid with
you our epics and decides what this
guy's ego trip does anything anyone
across the board has told me who has
worked with Michael Bay personally or
people who talk about Michael Bay
interviews sometimes stories of the
matter not if they're all consistent
he's a very ego driven guy and I don't
think he that's why I think he doesn't
listen to criticism for movies I just
don't think he listens to you know what
people have to say about his
Transformers films when he keeps
returning is they going to pay him a lot
of money
what the hell not and I can't tell what
these we did I guess like these
particular movies like why is this your
baby because I've seen other movie like
he seems to take break more breaks how
to do like smaller projects that maybe
even more interested in unless this is
just like now I'll keep doing these
because they make my life real
comfortable or something Emily got five
films now five and people drag your name
through the dirt alot like I don't know
if I believe him or not it's like part
of me really doesn't but the other part
of me like I don't know maybe it'll be
this I'm just like sort of watching it
all go by I'm thinking maybe this will
be the time he goes I've done this five
times I'm getting older every time he
says that people need to stop making a
big deal about it you know what we're
adding in that by making a video I mean
the thing is to like he doesn't need to
change them because they make tons of
money that's it for all vertically here
that the problem and I think they'd make
more money if the movie was actually
good look a Wonder Woman is doing Wonder
Woman was guaranteed to make money it's
guaranteed but because it's such a good
movie
it keeps breaking box-office records
area our paint value yeah exactly these
people will tune in and watch it again
and more people who've lost interest in
it will now go check it out
well I feel like transformers movies
that you know they're they're theater
based experience yeah that helps
whatever
but anyway Daniel day-lewis him actually
retiring I could believe that I know
many people have probably said it as
actors and actresses that they're
retiring and they actually do it yeah in
my lifetime hearing of an actor I really
knew of retiring the only one I know
who's stuck to his guns on that as Sean
Connery he's the only one I had on he
did he came back in that animated
Scottish movie sir Billy a couple of
years ago he did the lead character
voiceover yeah yeah it's really like yes
he did it was only a voice performance
but it's a Sean Connery [ __ ] liar he
could do it because I was like it was
that weird moment him like nobody
totally noticed
they're like oh I guess just because
it's from Scott okay well in front of
the camera he hasn't returned yeah okay
we gotta give him that he got a given
business it's pretty Kermit well Daniel
day-lewis he didn't retire they use
retired for a few years and he was like
doing something was serious and
apparently no no rapport we got was like
he was making shoes or shiny [ __ ] back
in Italy or whatever he doesn't talk
about it he keeps it very mysterious as
Daniel day-lewis tends to be I'm not
sure where it came from of why he
retired I know he came back as Martin
Scorsese found him and called him and
asked him to be in gangs in New York and
he caught that bug again to keep going
for it it wasn't just like one more one
that's right that's right I imagine like
Scorsese came to him he was like
cradling a shoe like in deep meditation
in the woods like long ass beard like
holder it's just like hey we need you
back and it's like I left that cable it
was the beginning of commander yeah just
like that
let's get back I don't know if he's got
it in the second time I mean it's
amazing that he came back and when he
comes back he wins two more Oscars yeah
I feel like he could he can come back
any time and sweep yeah I think it would
be cool if he retires because he
develops some type of split personality
disorder where you really turns into all
these characters James McAvoy from split
but it's all the Daniel day-lewis their
jerseys like yeah or just like I imagine
like each time he retires he goes to
that scene from Tropic Thunder yeah like
Robert Downey jr. is coming out of layer
after layer of makeup and like taking on
dad whose mannerisms like creepy I mean
I have my speculations as to why a guy
like that might want to retire because
his acting method is known to be
incredibly extreme yes credibly
extremely we don't really need to go in
a full details all the craziness he's
done for so many of his roles he does
more than just stay in character on so
known for being really engager offset he
lives that like heracross
because he said that he doesn't know any
other way anymore I heard a phrase once
a long time ago that mine is like a
parachute once you open it and expand it
it never goes back to its original shape
and I feel like Daniel day-lewis well a
I just wouldn't wanted to be what Robert
De Niro and Pacino do now yeah you know
they're just not giving it their all and
day-lewis he's not the kind of guy to
half-ass something he's gonna go full-on
into character for it on and I he wants
to feel like this the life when he did
in the name of our Father he went to
prison for a few weeks and he said like
yeah he just knew no other way to like
really know what it's like to be in
prison yeah like it isn't relying up on
his imagination I need to be as real and
positive
the only way I want to give you guys a
good for yeah and maybe day-lewis is at
a point in his life where they I mean
that day that just sounds mentally and
emotionally draining exhausting and
maybe choose to Tiffany so after all
this here is what the mighty just be me
maybe that's the thing is everybody goes
off into things in private he doesn't
want to tell anybody because he doesn't
know what they are either yeah I mean a
few retires I mean good for him it's
it's sad because he's are you believe I
met many would argue he's the best actor
ever because he never had that down flip
you know yeah my always a taking in
approaches a Pacino hero death to me I
put him in that category best actors
ever I would say that and then after you
notice there they start doing these like
phoning it in cashing in the money
getting that check in the half-ass
perform and then I am where do I attach
I just don't say to the best I say they
still have some of the best performances
ever but best from actor ever no I can't
really give him that but Daniel
day-lewis I mean he retired one time on
a great note and then he comes back out
of retirement with two more Oscars
I mean this week's began is like keys
lose like James Cameron with Avatar man
who's like you think you could say
number one at the box office watch I'll
show you guys the Mayans not why love it
yeah log is on ticking I don't know if
I'd wanted to return after a second time
over sorry maybe one last for us if you
didn't want to do that rule of threes
just one last performance in it yeah
then he dies and he gives his Oscar
speech for that one yeah and it'll be
yeah Scorsese's and lasha nation by John
who Susan or he should retire and come
back for one last two raw and like a
Farrelly Brothers Comedy I wanted him to
do like a screwball comedy just to see
what his method would be hate it out you
know cuz it would be fascinating no
matter what compacted host SNL
so what Daniken's do I should find a way
to make this all one character with
split personality that we could stay in
character the entire time yes six months
to prepare for his guest appearances one
week like everyone else no he gets six
months for these guesses no I know he's
gonna retire so that he can work for for
you know how many sketches are in the
show roughly like you know 10 40 50 each
one of those going to take a couple
years to prepare for and just properly
oscillated means yet you know season
season 60 of yeah SML he was really like
the one Peter Jackson was gunning for to
be Aragorn really yeah I think you would
have hated his life I think you would
have hated his life yeah I was in
character for four years why would Peter
Jackson wish that upon occasions like
you know he's going to do that we know
it is gonna be special but oh man oh man
I feel sorry for him you have to like
really go through a heavy treatment to
like find him get a guy with commitment
but not Alice my conclusion and Michael
Bay's will is [ __ ] he will return as
long as this movie makes a [ __ ] ton of
money over Aegina I'm sure there's a way
one of the stories I had there will
always be a way for him to return to
that and and Daniel day-lewis is his
main thing his main passion his main
dislike what defines him so much is
being an actor's more than just a job or
a gig to him so I feel like yeah he'll
take a few years off but I wouldn't be
surprised if he came back around yeah I
mean it's the only right foot ha ha
universe universe yeah hey Luis dagger
do cinematic universe
oh he just plays every single character
is the greatest film of all time
oh and we can get we can get Terrence
Malick to make yeah I think you got like
I feel like I've been thinking about
this lately with the whole Steven
Soderbergh thing like I feel like any
creative person is there's a good chance
you'll try it again at some point we
could take enough time off from that
yeah I just got imagine if you have the
bug you'll probably find yourself
itching for it again
you know like Johnny Depp doesn't seem
that the kind of guy who loves acting
and especially hear me interviews and
stuff so he comes out one day or even I
paid off all debts
he's like I'm retiring I believe him I
totally believe like yeah he's been
saved a long time he just does this for
the money I totally believe him but
someone like Donald a Lewis and I can
see you coming back it's not this one
just a job the right prod is like an
another guy worry it'll always just be
the right project ya know hey guys
Mel Gibson up giving me an order
subscribe to the real rejects oops
that notification bill yeah that John
Humphrey is on instagram and twitter
twitter
he's also the social media manager of
plumb house comm also mission of all
things go check out our exclusive person
video content over at patreon.com slash
the real regions